so guys I've spoken to you about the
reverse plank about the side plank but
I've not really spoken to you about the
regular
plank no not that
one yeah that's the one so a lot of
people think that the front plank is too
basic of a movement so basic in fact
that it has barely any utility for
anybody this couldn't be further from
the truth because the front plank is
actually a far more nuanced and
interesting exercise than people give it
credit for it can help you to build a
solid core but it can also teach you
important beneficial movement patterns
that will help you with healthier
everyday movement as well as advanced
skills you just need to know how to get
the very most out of it and adapt it to
fit your particular level that's what
we're going to do right
now so I think nearly everyone knows the
basics of plank it looks like this
essentially what you're doing is putting
your weight on your hands and on your
feet and then keeping the rest of your
body raised off the ground what you
might not know is that this is an
anti-extension movement what that means
is that you're using an isometric
contraction using the strengthen your
core to prevent your spine from
extending because if I were to let go of
any tension just sag I'd go like that
and that's extension in my spine so in
order to prevent myself doing that we
call it anti- extension and to achieve
this I'm using my rectus abdomin the
sheet of muscle on the front of my
stomach which gives me a six-pack which
is one of the reasons people quite like
doing plank in the first place I'm also
using my transverse abdomino the sling
of muscle around the core which helps to
keep your stomach sucked in nice and
flat and also braces it against movement
now actually anti- extension is really
important for preventing injury a great
example of this is if you're someone who
wears a ruck sack or any kind of bag
every day to work if you do this then
you've got weight pulling backwards and
down on you for an extended period of
time if you're weak in this area that
could eventually lead to an
overextension and injury at the same
time even when you lift something in
front of you you might be lifting it in
front of you but you often lift and lean
back in order to hoik it up into place
this can lead to injury if you don't
have that anti-extension strength to
straighten yourself back up again even
when you throw something you extend
backwards and then Flex forwards so you
need that anti- extension to drive power
and also to keep a nice stable spine
this becomes even more important in
moves like the handstand where you want
to keep a nice straight body as far as
possible if you go too far into
extension it's very hard to get back
this happens to me a lot you end up with
an ugly banana handstand and of course
it's really important for movements like
the front lever where you're hanging
from your arms because your legs want to
extend down behind you and you're
fighting that to stay in position so
advanced calisthenics athletes can also
benefit from anti-extension
now what many people will tell you is
the problem with the plank in this
regard is that it's just not challenging
enough there's not enough resistance to
really challenge yourself in that anti-
extension position or to build thick and
defined looking ABS it's therefore used
as a kind of rehab exercise for the
elderly but even then people are like is
this enough but guys I'm not completely
dense I know what you're thinking you're
thinking cut the foreplay tell us about
the drip so this is Barbell Apparel
today's sponsor so Barbell Apparel as
you can see make really nice clothes
designed specifically for those with a
more active lifestyle for your gym goers
and your athletes it fits really well it
looks great if you've got a more
muscular frame it's very flattering
without being you know too Johnny muscle
but it's also made from really nice high
quality material like this t-shirt feels
really nice to wear the designs are
really good as well you've got a wide
range of different things you can wear
all of which look great they have active
wear for at the gym of course but they
also have smarter clothing your jeans
your shirts which have all of those same
properties and they have like the best
customer service tailored specifically
to people like you and me if you tear up
your gym clothes in a particularly
intense workout they will replace them
for you completely for free and guys
this is actually a really good time to
buy because Barbell Apparel is currently
running a big discount right now you can
get any pair of jeans chinos or pants
for just $99 each use code bioner to get
a free shirt with any purchase over $98
this includes performance shirts click
the link below to check out my
collection bbel
aol.com
bioner but this is kind of missing the
point because very often when you inj
yourself lifting something it's not
lifting something extremely heavy
usually it's either lifting something at
an awkward angle or lifting something at
the end of a long day when you're
feeling fatigued or of course both this
is where we need strength endurance
meaning we need to be strong for an
extended period of time and therefore
giving ourselves a lighter resistance
for a longer period of time is where the
plank can be really useful but at the
same time we can also use the plank in a
number of other ways we can adapt it to
become more difficult or we can adapt it
to slightly alter the angle and at the
same time the plank is useful for
teaching us proper posture how to
position our spine and then ingraining
that movement pattern so that we move
properly and healthily throughout the
day and so that we can access that
position quickly when we need it for
things like advanced calisthenics so
let's look at how to do that shall
we so something you need to keep in mind
when you're performing the plank is the
alignment of your core because there's
more to it than just keeping a straight
back for example you need to think about
whether you want to tuck your
tailbone or not if you tuck your
tailbone it's going to make a straighter
back this is generally what's
recommended to people when we sit at a
desk we often sit with a slight anterior
pelvic tilt that means the pelvis is
tilted forwards by tucking it in like so
we can actually address this to an
extent however we don't actually walk
around like this most of the time and
some people actually have the opposite
problem they have a posterior pelvic
tilt and so for them they might want to
practice trying to keep their buttocks
nice to neutral it depends on your goals
if you have lower back pain then
consider aiming to keep a neutral pelvis
because this is how we actually walk
around and move if you know you have an
anterior pelvic tilt then practicing
tucking the tailbone is a great way to
combat that and if you're practicing for
moves like the planch then it's good
practice to keep a tucked tailbone so
you can practice that there as well that
then brings us onto the shoulder blades
whether we want to retract or protract
protracting the shoulder blades means
pushing through the ground with your
arms locked out so you lock out your
arms then you push further by pushing
through the shoulders this is again the
position you want if you're training for
moves like the plant so if you're into
your calisthenics this is the position
you want to maintain that said some
people suffer from rounded shoulder
blades so you might want to practice
keeping them neutral once again
retracting them isn't the best idea you
can use exercises like the swamp instead
just keep them nice and neutral along
with the spine and now you're practicing
keeping a nice core you want to keep the
ABS nice and tight at the same time to
train the rectus abdomin and the
transverse abdomin and even if you're
super strong hold this for a couple of
minutes you're going to start feeling it
especially if you're engaging the
muscles the way that you should be
contract the glutes as well then of
course there are all the different
variations of plank which you can use to
make the move harder easier or just
different so that you're placing
different forces on your body obviously
resting on your forearms is a simple way
to make the plank a lot easier you can
also rest on your knees if you want to
and build up I said earlier that a lot
of people think the plank is extremely
easy but they forget just how many
people are out there and that they've
probably been training for a long time
and watching a lot of content on YouTube
there's no shame if you can't do the
full plank it is a difficult movement
and you can build up to it that said if
you want to make the move more difficult
then You' got a few great options as
well you can remove one
hand this of course makes it into an
anti-rotation movement because your body
now wants to rotate towards the ground
you now have to use your obliques and
transer abdomin in order to prevent that
from happening and to keep your body
nice and straight grunt just made a
great video about building an iron core
using a leg raise variation he made some
great points about how having a weaker
core actually makes you less energy
efficient because you lose so much
energy when you move he talked about how
it can help you to balance better having
a stronger core and so by training moves
like this anti-rotational plank you can
develop that and move far more
athletically and again it's also great
for injury prevention you guys know that
I really like rotation and anti-rotation
you can also raise one leg if you want
to make it more difficult still and of
course this is great for building up to
a one armed pushup alternatively another
way to make this much more difficult is
to stretch your arms out long in front
of you this makes it more like a lan
push-up not only does this longer lever
arm mean you're actually fighting more
Force you're increasing the resistance
but it changes the center of gravity so
that it's nearer to your lower back and
this is where it gets really challenging
because you still don't want to create
that curve in the lower back this is how
a lot of us can create injury during
movement and it's something I'm
struggling with too focus on holding
this position without letting your lower
back cave in this is a great way to
build a really strong and durable core
and of course it translates to cool
moves like the Lan push-up like the
dragon flag and then of course you've
got all the more moving variations you
can go from this kind of plank to on
your hands you can do ab rollouts which
I might make a whole video about one day
or you can do walkouts whatever there's
tons of variation to the plank there's
no reason for you to look down on it or
think that it's not useful even the most
basic version of the plank is really
powerful and once you throw in these
variations and focus on engaging the
correct muscles it becomes invaluable so
thanks a ton for watching guys I hope
you found this video useful and
interesting let me know in the comments
down below if you use the plank or if
it's something you're going to start
using now if you want more Good Vibes
and cool moves then consider subscribing
to the bioner and I'll see you next time
thanks for watching and bye for
now